So s want to make virtual
reality applications?
Great!
Let's get started.
In this quick tutorial,
I'll teach you
how to use the Java SDK to
make your application truly 3D.
You may have noticed that
rendering for virtual reality
is different from normal
Android applications.
I'm guessing you're using
some sort of a graphics API,
like OpenGL, or maybe a
higher-level framework.
If you haven't thought
about that yet,
then take your time to decide.
It is really important
to get it right.
Our own treasure
hunt demo is using
OpenGL ES 2.0 for rendering
the graphics in 3D.
Now that you have
decided on your renderer,
it is time to download the SDK.
Got it?
Let's go!
The first thing you need
to do is add some tags
to your manifest file.
Cardboard requires the use
of API Level 16 or higher.
The Cardboard SDK requires
read and write permissions.
So it compared the user's
phone to the Cardboard viewer.
The NFC permission is required
to access the NFC tag present
in some Cardboard viewers.
And the device should
always be in landscape mode.
This is because the user is
going to be moving their head,
and the orientation should
not change as they do so.
Therefore, it is
important for you
to lock the screen
orientation to landscape.
It is recommended for you to
handle orientation and keyboard
configuration changes to avoid
having your application being
reset as these changes occur.
And finally, if you
want your application
to show inside a
Cardboard app listing,
then you should add the
Cardboard intent-filter.
This is highly recommended,
and can help people
discover your application.
So make sure you add it.
Now let's get to programming.
Start by extending your activity
from Cardboard activity.
The Cardboard activity
exposes Cardboard events,
such as the trigger, and
handles common things required
for virtual reality rendering,
like hiding the system UI
by using Android immersive mode.
Your activity should also
implement the CardboardView
StereoRenderer interface.
This interface handles
stereoscopic rendering
and simplifies your work by
initializing open [INAUDIBLE]
for you, and giving you the
correct matrices for drawing
the scene fully [INAUDIBLE].
Normally, an Android
user interface elements
are built using views.
In virtual reality, we
have just one view element,
which we are using as
a surface to render to.
This is the CardboardView.
Add the CardboardView
to your layout XML
in the following way.
Then, in the activity class,
initialize the CardboardView
by setting the renderer
and the view like this.
It is time to implement
the StereoRenderer.
The only frame callback is
called once every new frame,
before it is drawn.
This is a good time to
update any render data,
such as animation and physics.
The callback comes with
the head transform data.
This class contains the
position and orientation
of the user's head.
You can use this for calculating
where the user is looking at,
and what the user is interacting
with in the environment,
such as objects,
and user interface.
You can also use this for
first time calling, introducing
the [INAUDIBLE]
when [INAUDIBLE].
Drawing should be done in
the onDrawEye callback.
This callback is called
twice every frame,
as it is required to draw
the scene for both eyes.
And the call contains
the eye class.
Inside is the view matrix,
offsets, and orientation
for the eye being rendered.
This data correctly offsets the
camera's position for the eye,
creating the
stereoscopic effect.
Note that a view
[INAUDIBLE] is also
set for you, dividing
the screen in two halves.
Again, one half for an eye.
Simply combine the eye
matrix with your own view
matrix for correct rendering.
Now that we have
rendering working,
let's talk about input.
While looking around
can be fun, it
is more fun if you can
interact with the environment.
That is why Cardboard
has the trigger.
To use the trigger,
simply implement
the onCardboardTrigger callback.
This would be called as the
user activates the trigger.
Remember that you only
have one button, so
make sure to use it wisely.
Make everything work by context.
Looking on a button,
and using the trigger,
should activate the button.
However, if the user is
looking somewhere else,
you'll want to make something
else happen, instead, or maybe
nothing.
Sometimes it is enough
to activate things
only by looking at them.
For example, a
button can animate
as the user looks at it,
and activate its action
after a second or two.
This also applies to
parts of the scene.
You can highlight objects,
and activate animations,
as the user looks around.
For example, if a butterfly
is sitting on a tree,
you can make it
animate and fly around,
as the user looks at it.
This way, you know the user
isn't missing any of the scene,
and you are not forcing
them to try and interact
with everything manually.
Now that you know how
to make everything work,
it is important to keep in mind
some best practices in order
to make a compelling
virtual reality experience.
The three most important
rules to remember
are, always keep
tracking on; keep stable
60 frames per second, or higher;
and avoid unexpected motion.
One of the things that makes
virtual reality compelling
is the ability to look around.
In contrast, it would
feel extremely unnatural
if the camera stopped
responding to your head.
Therefore, you should
always take into account
the user's orientation,
and never freeze the camera
or force the user to
look somewhere specific.
If you want to grab
the user's attention,
use cues, such as
light and sound,
to direct them to
look where you want.
You can also delay activating
an event in your scene
until you know the
user had turned
their head in that direction.
That way, they have time to take
things in, and enjoy the scene.
You must always keep
to 60 FPS or higher.
Not only does it contribute
to a good user experience,
but it is even more
crucial in virtual reality.
Think about it this
way-- the screen
is the only thing
the user can see.
Rendering at 60 FPS means
the user sees the same frame
for 16.6 milliseconds.
If you miss 60 FPS, vsync
drops you to 30 FPS,
and its frame is shown
for 33 milliseconds.
That means, as the
user moves their head,
they are getting an incorrect
image for a very long time.
This is why it is very
important for virtual reality
applications to be
fast and responsive.
Movement can be tricky,
because the user does not
feel like they are in motion.
If the world starts
moving around,
it can contribute
to an odd feeling
if there is discrepancy between
one's actual lack of movement
and what the user is seeing.
There are ways to
convey movement safely.
For example, by keeping
motion constant,
and avoiding acceleration.
Or by using another object
and making it move first,
or creating a path
for the user to see.
This signals to the user
they're about to be moved,
and subconsciously
prepares them.
There are many more ways to
ensure good user experience.
I recommend you to check
out the Cardboard Design Lab
application, to learn more about
good and bad design patterns,
so you can create the best
user experience in your game
or application.
Good luck with making your own
virtual reality experience.
And make sure to post about
it in our Cardboard community.
[MUSIC PLAYING]